why is an origin story it's it's why we
get out of bed in the morning and it's
why people care it's this deep-seated
purpose cause or belief it's a spark
inside of us and it's present all the
time it's different than motivation
inspiration is different than motivation
motivation to be externally driven it
can be temporary
you could be motivated for fear of
punished you know if you're gonna get
punished you can be motivated and if
you're gonna get rewarded you can be
motivated but it doesn't last that
feeling goes away and you have to keep
repeating it inspiration as this is this
little thing that burns inside of us
sometimes brighter sometimes dimmer but
it's always there and it's where we go
to for that internal strength and it's
fueled by our idealism and it's fueled
by the love of our friends and our
colleagues and our co-workers and our
family that's what keeps that spirit
alive and I sort of I make a point to
distinguish the differing positivity and
optimism you know it's important for us
to be optimistic now and and to me
positivity isn't it's not a positivity
is like looking at the world and saying
everything's good but the world is
difficult right now you know so but
optimism is about being in a dark tunnel
and seeing the light and you're not
focused on the tunnel you're focused on
the light optimism is not the denial of
the current state it's the belief that
if we keep moving we will hit the light
I don't know how far away that light is
I don't know how long it's gonna take us
to get there but I know a hundred
percent that if we keep moving towards
it we will hit it and that's optimism
that it amount of optimism allows for
darkness to exist optimism allows for
reality to be there optimism allows for
us to have good days and bad days it
allows optimism it allows us to have
setbacks if you say be positive that
disallows a setback that dis allows you
to wake up in the morning and and feel
that you don't want to you don't want to
do the day you know optimism says so
take a break today do it do it tomorrow
you know optimism allows for reality and
I think that's really important that it
that I'm not sure it's important for us
to be positive right now but it is
definitely important
to be optimistic
[Music]
you